stephen miller is a former advisor to
the trump white house he joins us
tonight to assess what we're seeing this
this seems like a complete collapse and
a disaster you know i don't cable news
is famous for overstatement i don't want
to i don't want to be that guy but that
the picture suggested how do you assess
it
the only danger right now tucker is that
we understate the problem okay the only
danger is that we fail to convey to
people
what is happening before our very eyes
every few days a camp the size of del
rio is admitted into our country
day after day week after week let me
tell you a story i was talking to a
front line immigration officer who works
in arizona he says that people from all
around the world they book flights to
tijuana they book flights to northern
border towns in mexico they pay a small
bus fare to drive one hour to the border
in arizona they walk up to border agents
they turn themselves in
children families teenagers and single
adults
on the certainty on the certainty that
they will be admitted into the country
that is how mad things have gotten you
know benjamin franklin said when
describing our form of government that
we have a republic
if you can keep it it is not hyperbole
but fact to say that at this moment in
time we do not have a republic because
the basic principle of a republic
is self-government by citizens right and
so if you have millions of uninvited
people and the citizens of this country
have no ability to exercise control over
who can join the polity then it is no
longer a republic because all of your
work all of your sweat all of your toil
will go to benefit people who have no
right to be here
that's where we are right now
you know i i've asked this before and i
don't want to single out the governor of
texas who i think is a nice person i
agree with him on a lot and everything
greg abbott but it seems to me the only
solution i can think of anyway is for
the texas national guard to say it's our
state we're securing our border you
can't do this and if that provokes some
kind of crisis with the federal
government so be it but why doesn't he
do that is there some reason that i
can't think of
well what you're describing is the use
of article four section four and that
relates exactly to the point that i was
making it's known as the guarantee
clause and it says that the federal
government in effect shall guarantee to
every state a republican form of
government
protection against invasion and
protection against domestic violence all
three
all three of those tasks
have been failed by the biden
administration so they're violating
their commitments under article four
section four which i would argue
does in fact empower any border state
to control their own sovereign territory
and if they don't and if somebody
doesn't hold this presidency accountable
there won't be a country in a period of
time i agree with that greg abbott is
the one man who can stop this and let's
hope he does it tonight for real
stephen miller thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else